On we go. Can't complain, we get another white and we get a strong opponent. Parthi Chess
from India and another Sicilian. Awesome. So this is an Aleppan day and this will probably be a
separate YouTube video. So people watching on YouTube, I'm recording this right after playing
the previous Aleppan game which was its own video. That was the 20 move win where we won the queen at
the end the same night. Hopefully we get another convincing win. All right once again we face D5.
Once again we face D5 and this time we face the line that I recommended for black. So this is
actually kind of cool. This is the line that I recommend to most people against the Aleppan
for several reasons. I think objectively it's quite good. White can obtain a slight advantage
if he knows a load of theory. I will admit I'm pretty rusty on the theory here myself.
But even if white plays all the correct moves you get a pretty enterprising and unbalanced
position. So in terms of playing against the Aleppan for a win, Knight f6 is really second
to none and most people who play the Aleppan don't really study this line. It falls through
the cracks and black can definitely get an advantage if white doesn't handle this accurately.
So the point of knight f6 of course is to recapture with the knight which is a more convenient way
to recapture the pawn. The downside may appear to be that white has c4 but as you already hopefully
have picked up from multiple speedrun games c4 is not a solution to white's problems because
black responds with e6 and in the event of the trade black gets total monopoly over the key
central squares and full compensation for the pawn. And I'll explain that, reiterate that after
the game. We will check the Aleppan Bible after this game because I will fully confess that I
am blanking on what their recommended line is. It might be a check on a4. I think it is a check
on a4 but that's not what we're going to play here. I do know a very practical line. I've played
it in blitz and although black can equalize with very accurate play it does pose a lot of problems
at least initially and we will test our opponent's knowledge of this line. The move that we're going
to start with is bishop to b5 check which should be on your radar as a very natural move because it
forces a piece to land on d7 and as a consequence of that the contact between the queen and the d5
pawn has been severed. Black plays knight bd7 which is the correct move. And now that the knight
is occupying an awkward square and the black bishop will have a hard time getting out this is
when we choose to open up the center. So this is where rather than trying to cling to this pawn
with the move c4 which is a very theoretical line. Black responds with a6 and then a quick b5
very dangerous for white and rather than trying something like queen f3 to which black can again
respond with a6 and ultimately the knight will jump out to e5 it'll have the opposite effect.
Now is the time when we strike with d4. Now we strike with d4. So we open up the center.
Obviously if black plays knight takes d5 then we can capture the pawn on c5. The pawn cannot
be recaptured because the knight is pinned and the knight on d5 is suddenly going to be hanging. dc
is a discovered attack. If black plays c takes d4 then we can recapture with the queen. Our queen is
almost shielded by the pawn on d5 which acts kind of like an umbrella. So the queen on d4 is not
going to be easy to attack and unless black is very very precise here it's easy to end up a pawn
down for no compensation. I don't even fully remember how black is supposed to play this
which is kind of a good thing. a6 here might be the best move. We'll check all of this with
the engine and with the book after the game. So hold all of your opening thoughts. This is
definitely a a gap that we that we need to fill from both sides. Yeah because if you kind of just
visually look at the position after cd queen d4 it looks bad for black right. It doesn't look like
black is anywhere near recovering the pawn on d5 and once we do that then c4 becomes a lot
more palatable of a possibility because once the center is opened the move c4 does not contain any
downsides whereas playing it here with the pawn still sitting on d2 that's where the problems
come from because after c4 e6 and the trade that pawn becomes a backward pawn and that
correspondingly the square on d4 is a big outpost that black can use for their knight.
Okay so black continues to ponder his next move. Woodwood asks after knight takes d5 dce6
does white play b4? I wouldn't play b4. I think there there was c6 in that position but we'll
explore that after the game. Our opponent has played a6 which i'm 99% sure is in fact the
correct move. Now bishop a4 would be too stubborn and counterproductive because it would merely
enable black to expand on the queen side with b5. More importantly it would give black the
fianchetto square for free for the light squared bishop. So definitely not bishop a4. Definitely
not bishop c4. Again the point is not to cling to the extra pawn it's to use the pawn as a bargaining
chip and gain a lead in development in return for that pawn which is currently an extra pawn. So
by recapturing it black simply equalizes the material. So we make a modest move. We make a
modest move. Those of you who've seen all of the speedrun videos might remember that you have a
similar kind of idea which I recommend it against. I think it's called the Portuguese variation of
the Scandinavian where you throw in the check on b5 and then drop the bishop all the way back to e2.
Why not d3? Because again that destroys the connection between the queen and the pawn.
Bishop d3 black can capture on d4 and what we do not want is an isolated queen pawn position
where black's knight is already blockading the square in front of it. Instead we drop back to
e2 and we simply continue developing our pieces. I think against Narayanan I played this in a rapid
blitz game. I think I might have tried an early c4 and d5 and I did manage to get a good position
in that game. So let me think for a second. What do we want to do here? Of course the sort of
natural move is knight f3 but I really do like the look of c4 here driving the pawn down to d5
kind of Benoni style. I know there's a lot of theory in that position. Let's try c4. Let's try
to be as principled as possible because we will not get another chance to play c4 and d5. Why not?
Because if black's pawn had already been on e6 here then the move d5 would be completely
counterproductive because after the trade our pawn on d5 would be a sitting duck and black
would pick it off with the knights and the queen. Now of course if black plays e6 we invite that
because we take on e6 and we ruin black's structure. I think white is a little bit better
here. Okay g6 so our opponent is playing this kind of like a Benoni. We need to develop our
pieces right? We've made enough pawn moves to last us a lifetime. I don't think it even matters
what move we start with knight c3 knight f3. Not of principal importance. Let's start with knight c3.
Now let's bring the other knight out to f3 and let's get our king out of the center. Presumably
our opponent will do the same and I think black's position is pretty unpleasant here. Now we could
also throw in the move h3 which would be a typical move that you often see in these types of positions
just covering the g4 square but I'm not concerned about knight g4 so I think it's more important for
us to develop. Also meriting attention was the move a4. If you're familiar with the Benoni you
probably know that b7 b5 is one of black's main sources of queenside counterplay and here as well
black could contemplate the move b5. It's a very advanced move because here it involves a pawn
sacrifice kind of Benko gambit style and I'm not convinced that it's sound in this position
but you know a soviet school boy might have played a4 just to cardinally prevent the possibility of
b5. Of course a4 has certain positional downsides. It weakens the b4 square but that square is not
going to be easy to occupy. There is neither of black's knights will be able to easily make their
way to b4. Yeah so black is worse I think because we've got a space advantage. We've got a nice pawn
wedge in the center. We've got clear subsequent development for our pieces right. Bishop can come
out to g5 or maybe e3 in order to pressure the pawn. Then we can play queen d2 and our opponent
does indeed play b5. Okay I'm pretty impressed that you know that he was able to come up with
this idea because it takes a knowledge of kind of Benko gambit style concepts but I'm pretty
skeptical about its soundness. Obviously we need to call the bluff because otherwise we'll have
this pawn to get to b4 or we allow black to take on c4. We might as well accept the sacrifice. We
don't need to think about that. Black takes back. Okay so again there's no question that we're
going to take the pawn on b5. Which piece should we capture it with? Well I think that question
has an obvious answer. Knight takes b5 seems very awkward to me. Not only because it opens up the
diagonal for black's bishop but mostly because we take our eyes off of the d5 pawn. It's entirely
it's entirely possible that black will ultimately win that pawn back but we don't want to go down
without a fight and after knight takes b5 knight b6 suddenly we only have one defender on the pawn
and black has three attackers. Maybe we could push the pawn to d6 in that position and kind of make
that work but that just seems like it goes in the wrong direction. Bishop takes b5 a lot more natural
keeping the knight on its natural square and of course the bishop could later on dive into c6 and
hit the rook and protect the pawn from a nice square. Now typical in the benko is to initiate
the trade of light squared bishops with bishop a6. This is a move that you do see very frequently in
the benko but in contrast to the benko which I'll show after the game. So if you're watching this on
youtube and you I don't know what the benko gambit is first of all you can always pause the video
and just google it then you'll go down the rabbit hole and start watching benko videos. It's a gambit
that occurs after 1d4 and the mechanism is exactly the same. Black plays c5 and then b5
and it's fallen out of favor at the top level in recent years. White is considered to be sort of
solidly better several different ways but among club players it's still a very dangerous weapon.
It's absolutely still playable and the bottom line is that black develops in return for the pawn
long lasting pressure on the queen side. But here it seems like we've already castled which is
a big advantage for us. We've already brought our knights out and black just doesn't have all that
much stuff going on the queen side. The knight on d7 is passive. The pawn on c5 is weak. This seems
like a seriously inferior benko. But in general not to belabor the point our opponent is taking
his time though so when you hear players or commentators mention oh this is like a benoni
structure this is a benko like idea it's normally it normally refers to some opening where the idea
in question is more common than in the current opening. Like in the sicilian you rarely see
this type of sacrifice in the benko. It literally revolves around that sacrifice bishop b7.
Okay so what does our opponent want? Well probably he wants knight b6 after which the four pieces are
going to be attacking the d5 pawn. If we lose that pawn it's totally not the end of the world
but that might signal the end of our advantage. So what kinds of ideas come to mind here?
Well let's take a couple of moments. I need to think. My temptation was the move bishop c6 right
this seemed very tempting to me because in the event of the trade that pawn lands on c6 and
could even move to c7 potentially with a fork. But after bishop c6 black has this weird looking
move queen b6 which should be pretty obvious to you because it attacks the bishop two different
ways and in the event of the trade that queen fianchettoed on b7 is actually a very strong
piece and in the benko black often wants the queen to be precisely there. Why? Because it
pressures simultaneously both of white's weak pawns on d5 and b2. So we're ultimately helping
black get their pieces where they want them to go. We should find an alternate way of meeting
the threat of knight b6 and that's where the idea of bishop f4 comes in. Bishop f4 aims to meet
knight b6 with d6 so this was my first candidate option. My second was very similar bishop e3.
Similar mechanism tying black down to the c5 pawn. Bishop e3 if knight b6 then we capture
the pawn on c5 and we have connected passed pawns on the queen side which is a huge huge asset that
could be converted into victory in the event that the queens get traded. So bishop f4 and bishop e3
are my two big candidate moves. I like the look of bishop e3 because it's a little bit simpler
and I'll share some of my more detailed considerations after the game. I feel like
bishop b3 might be a little bit more precise. Our opponent immediately opts for the line in
question. Well we have no choice but to take on c5. Maybe I rushed. Maybe bishop c6 here was
possible. Maybe bishop c6 was strong. Not entirely sure. Anyways we'll explore that afterward. Knight
takes d5. Okay so now we need to navigate the complexities carefully right because we've got
a lot of pieces on black side of the board and they're undefended and you just got to be careful
not to blunder a fork or some and you know it's not the end of the world. Everything is pretty
well positioned. So in general right from a large scale bird's eye view perspective we want to trade
pieces. We now have connected passed pawns. Any end game be it a queen end game rook end game is
probably going to be winning for us. In the absence of a compelling reason not to we should trade
pieces. Minor pieces queens whatever we can and I don't see any reason that we shouldn't start
by trading the ponies by taking the knight on d5. Knight takes d5 and now I think we should
essentially continue our campaign to trade as many minor pieces as possible and to do it as
fast as possible. We have a nice way I think to pose a nasty little ultimatum to black. Either
you give up one of your main pieces the bishop on g7 or you drop your knight back and your pieces
become a lot more passive. What am I thinking about here? Yeah I'm really eyeing the move bishop d4
and it seems very appetizing. Let's go for it. Yeah obvious move threatening to trade the bishops
and then black will be saddled also with sort of weak king which could become annoying if the
queens remain on the board. I had to look at a move like knight to f4 right because the bishop on b7
is a pretty intimidating piece and moves like knight f4 always need to be considered but here
we actually take on g7 and we're able to force the queens off the board and that resulting endgame is
far from an obvious win. It might even be a draw but I feel like with the extra pawn we will as
long as we're able to keep black's initiative at bay the pawns should ultimately make their
presence felt. Thank you for the sub Kallio shirt but we'll think about it. We don't have to grab
the queens automatically. We can also keep the queens on the board. It's not the end of the world
so yeah our opponent is thinking. Of course knight f6 would avoid the trade of bishops but that would
be a positive for us because the knight would be brought away from the center and we could breathe
a little bit more easily rearrange our pieces and ultimately start pushing our pawns even if it's
the middle game. Yeah f6 would be music to my ears honestly. Maybe it's the best move. I don't know
maybe f6 and e5. There's a case to be made for that but it does seem incredibly weakening. E5
whoa what a move. That one I will admit I didn't even was not on my radar at all. So let's decipher
the idea. Now bishop takes e5 is the obvious recapture. I assume that black wants to take on e5
and after knight takes e5 bring the queen down to g5. Okay that is what I assume to be black's idea
and rather than just immediately panicking and saying oh okay let's trust our opponent let's
ponder that position for a second. After queen g5 the danger lies in the fact that black has
pressure on g2 and black has an attack on the knight but I think we have an ingenious tactical
solution in that position. We can force that bishop off the board with the move bishop c6
right so this is after takes takes takes queen g5. There I think we have the move bishop c6
and if black takes the knight then we take the bishop. If black takes the bishop then we recapture
with the knight. Black can threaten checkmate with knight f4 but it's just a one move threat
and I think we can handily defend against it with for example queen f3 and then we will emerge
two pawns up. Still we won't be out of the woods. Black has some initiative but it seems to me that
black's initiative will be dying out in that situation. We can also play knight takes e5 but
that one I like a lot less because then black can play the immediate knight f4 and our pieces just
kind of get tangled up in the center. So we want to play a little faster here we're going to leave
ourselves with some time. Let's play bishop e5 and call our opponent's bluff. Also possible by the
way I just realized was bishop c5. I completely missed that move but I actually like our choice
because bishop c5 e4 would have been a complete and utter mess even if we won the exchange. We'll
explore that afterward. Okay the other thing that I you know looked at a little bit is whether black
has a fork on these two minor pieces because both of them are undefended type one undefended pieces
but the queen has nowhere to attack both of them. Our queen e8 obviously blunders the queen
so that's the other thing that I made sure of. Other than queen g5 I don't see anything even
remotely scary. Maybe knight f4 but obviously then we can take the queens off the board
and with two extra pawns we should be fine. As long as we avoid g3 which runs into maiden one,
very common blunder, I think we'll be fine. So queen g5 bishop b5 to c6. Hopefully everybody
understands the logic behind that move. We attack the bishop on b7 and if the bishop takes we
recapture with a knight and as a nice bonus does anybody see what we're threatening in that
resulting position? It's probably not going to matter because black will play knight f4 anyway
but if black for example plays rook a c8 there and we have a sexy little tactic queen takes d5 yeah
very nice and then knight e7 check picks up the queen on d5 and I think perhaps our opponent has
spotted bishop c6 and is now trying to figure out an alternate yeah but it's just there's just not
enough firepower on the board we don't have any weaknesses and it's important not to be scared of
so queen g5 bishop c6 trade the move knight f4 there I think would be scary to a lot of players
and it should be scary right when a queen and the knight is attacking that by definition is scary
the queen and the knight the strongest tandem in chess but a main threat in and of itself isn't
scary we could just bring our queen up to f3 black has no other attackers whereas our rook is near
the king our knight could easily jump back into the center and we could push black's knight away
with a well-timed g3 yeah knight f4 here I've been thinking about what we want to do if he plays
knight f4 because the queen trade the funny thing there is that black's initiative does last into
the end game for three reasons first of all the g2 pawn is hanging second of all black has the d
file and the rook could infiltrate to d2 third of all remember these minor pieces are both undefended
they're on the same rank which means you should always be aware of a move like rook to d5 which
incidentally we might still have bishop c6 to the rescue but we don't want to engage in these
complications so knight f4 i'm actually more inclined to play a different move not to take
the queen what other moves are available to us after knight f4 yeah i think tom o bedlam got it
nothing has to change just because the queens are staring at each other we can still play the move
that we were planning to play anyway no no no don't play f3 because then queen b6 picks up the
bishop instead after knight f4 i think we can just still play bishop c6 and we can still trade the
bishops and if black wants to trade queens be our guest you know and we get the d file
so after knight f4 bishop c6 bishop takes c6 knight takes c6 if black plays queen g5 there
it simply transposes into the position that we've already been analyzing otherwise the queen doesn't
have any other great squares queen f6 we can go queen f3 there what should black play asks kavita
i don't know i think black is in big trouble i think black has virtually no compensation for
two pawns i would probably go queen g5 and stick with the initial idea probably i would go queen
g5 bishop c6 trade go knight f4 and after queen f3 play a move like rook ae8 and basically just
go all in and try to create something on the king side but yeah i think black is unless i'm
seriously mis-evaluating something or missing a concrete resource of some sort some computerish
idea i think black is borderline lost i do see a crazy idea that i'll reveal after the game unless
our opponent plays this move and queen f6 and that was the move that was the move uh that i had in
mind so the idea is you're luring white into 97 which appears to win the exchange what is black's
idea after 97 well then black plays queen g5 notice that bishop c6 is no longer possible but
you might think i don't i just take the rook but if you take the rook white's knight jumps out to e3
with a double attack right this is a discovery against g2 and white's queen is under fire there
i think white just collapses and loses the queen so after 97 queen g5 that position seems very
tactical and i'm not sure that it's worth going for it especially with a low time situation
unless we find something specific after 97 queen g5 so i'm going to take a couple moments here
and think about this because this is a high stakes position have an idea i'm just double checking it
57 queen g5 i'm eyeing the move queen to f3 which is a very risky move because we're putting the
queen right under the bishop's nose but i don't see any effective discoveries there and i think
and i think everything might be under control there there there let's say black moves the rook
and we can jump back to c5 with the knight and hit the bishop where it hurts
yeah i think we will go precisely for this idea let's go 97 let's go 97 and now we're just quickly
going to play this move not knight takes rook because of 93 but instead we bring our queen
to the rescue this might be a blunder you know i might be blundering something so the key concept
here is why would a move like this not occur to a lot of players well because you're putting the
queen where you're not supposed to put it but remember that pins are often two-way streets
this is what people might not understand yes the more valuable piece is usually the more vulnerable
piece because the stakes are less for black but still the bishop on b7 is just as undefended as
the queen is so this is dangerous for the queen but it's also dangerous for the bishop the knight
can't really move because the bishop is undefended that concept is important it allows you to
understand the value of a move like queen f3 is it risky yes could it be very rewarding also yes
also queen g3 is a safe move that we could play virtually regardless of black's response but we
could also go for more depending on where the rook moves i'm assuming the black will move his rook
rook yeah but rook a7 is a very ingenious move to defend the bishop but there i think we can
probably take the rook on f8 i think rook a7 we already can take because if black plays knight e3
there how should we respond in that position who can uh keep their composure knight rook a7 knight
takes f8 and knight e3 we ignore the knight because then we get checkmated where do we move our queen
yeah we just play queen g3 there because we're already up a rook so all we need to do is defend
against the immediate threat yeah harold lloyd brings up a great point great tactical eye if
black plays rook c8 there is a rook a to d1 with the threat of a double capture on d5 with knight
f6 check to follow but i feel like that's a little bit of one move itis black can defend against that
and i don't know if we want to burn our tempo on that threat i do think rook fc8 is black's best
move in fact i'm pretty confident because it prevents knight c5 so i think black should play
rook fc8 but then we've got time right rook fc8 black does not have any threats so we can make
a general improving move potentially such as even a move like rook fe1 could be considered
here rook fc8 played all right let's think give me 30 seconds so i've i've had a couple candidate
moves here and they all stem from the same general sentiment which is that white is not in a hurry i
don't see any threats for black surprisingly enough so we have the time and the luxury to
make an improving move and what does it mean to make an improving move here well we have the move
queen g3 which tries to get the queens off the board i like the move queen g3 i think it might
be the most practical option but we don't have to rush with queen g3 we can play that move next
so a move that i also like is rook f to e1 bringing the rook to an open file getting the
rook into the game the problem there might be the move rook to c2 so that's what i'm struggling with
right now i'm calculating a crazy line rook fe1 rook c2 rook e5 trying to give the rook up for
two pieces rook c1 check bishop f1 oh my gosh it gets pretty crazy there i don't really want that
rook a d1 actually the more i look at it the more i like it okay i have another idea
a4 is also very interesting just pushing the pawn let's go a4 which is the most anticlimactic
move ever it took three minutes for me to generate this move and i'll explain stuff in a lot greater
detail after the game i'll sort of walk you through all my calculations but right now i
don't want to lose on time the tldr is that i want this bishop to be defended because if the knight
moves away i don't want to deal with the queen's attack on the bishop i want to be able to focus
on the king side also this bishop is crucial because it defends the knight and the knight
is kind of stuck in black's territory so the last thing we would want is to lose the bishop
because then we might lose the knight so this allows me to focus on the king side and on
improving my position now we might even sacrifice the b2 pawn okay black finds this move now there's
knight b6 here which is interesting but i had my eyes on queen g3 now we're going to try to trade
now black doesn't have to opt for the trade but if he doesn't then that means the attack is over
and then we can finally focus on bringing our pieces into the game there is a very subtle tactical
line that i spent like two minutes calculating which occurs if black takes the queen and then
takes the pawn on b2 which i'm assuming our opponent will and maybe it doesn't work i mean
it's it's it's very tenuous and he does and we will and we drop our knight back that was that
was the move that i spent so long searching for but i actually am seeing a way for black to dodge
the loss of material we're almost winning wow there's a crazy idea for black here that i did
overlook now we'll still have winning chances here no matter what obviously because we're up a pawn
now i thought this won the game because the bishop is attacked and if black defends it well then we
take it and play bishop c6 forking the rook and the knight on d5 but i won't say this until black
moves and black finds it so bishop c6 i missed rook a5 counter-attacking the knight okay let's
not panic let's let's figure out a way to keep the pressure going must be something here i just
don't have time to figure it out some sort of magnus would find a very strong move here in
an instant i like the look of even rook fc1 very simple move yeah just rook fc1 looks very very
strong here too let's play it just improving the position and obviously we now reinforce the threat
of bishop c6 because the knight is protected also we're keeping an eye on rook takes b5
it's very important that the rooks defend each other let's not move a rook off of the first rank
now okay bishop f5 that might have been a blunder because let's consider bishop c6 i'm assuming that
our opponent wants rook d8 but does anybody see what move we have in that position that might
finally topple black's resistance bishop c6 rook d8 the rook and the queen they're not particularly
good defenders because they're easy pieces to attack we have knight c5 to b7 the bishop and
the knight are the heroes of this game they're constantly rearranging to form new threats
this is i think the move black finally overlooks and this might do it
this might do it only 28 moves it's crazy how short this game has been and how much has happened
i think this ends it black is out of squares okay and our opponent is desperation now let's be
precise don't grab the knight you know it's like you're grabbing the first type of candy that you
see try to be accurate it's much more accurate to take the rook here and after rook takes b7 to
return to c6 and pick off the knight then we'll be up a rook and the game ends very nice gg i have
to call our opponent played a fantastic game this was this was close and there's a lot to analyze so
let's try to do it as carefully as we can so first order of business is for us to educate ourselves
on this line and i am going to grab our aleppan bible
note that the second reliable source on the aleppan is the new chessable course that came
out by ganguli and kasim janov that you can find on chess well i could check that one as well but
we will limit ourselves to the book squeezing the sicilian by alexander khalif man yeah knight f6
queen a4 i was my hunch was correct yeah the queen a4 check this is the move that is recommended by
khalif man black might have unnecessary difficulties to regain his pawn on d5 bishop d7
is the only move that they know that is not the only move they give there's bishop d7
and there's night bd7 obviously queen d7 does not deserve any analysis if bishop d7
then the queen is dropped back to b3 this is a nice square queen b6 is virtually forced otherwise
black is not going to be able to even try to regain the pawn they also give queen c7 just bishop c4
so you actually load the pieces up on this pawn and it's not just the extra pawn that's the problem
black can't move like this pawn is restricting black's development in a big way this is plus
minus queen e5 checks simply 92 and black is already losing because d4 is coming next
so queen b6 here is the main line and now you keep the tension with bishop c4
they give knight a6 the only way to develop now we develop as well and black brings the knight
around to c7 very typical maneuver in this line and here they give the move d4 so the general
concept here is similar you wait for the appropriate moment to open up the center and when you open up
the center you are giving the pawn back but as a consequence you're going to get a big initiative
in the middle game or in the end game in this case queen takes b3 a takes b3 black is able to
win the pawn back cd 94 they also mentioned the move d6 giving the pawn away but ruining black's
pawn structure it's an interesting alternative but in their main line we get this end game
and white is slightly better no question about it because white's pieces are very nicely placed
black is cramped white's got you know obvious control of the a file and a very mobile
pawn mass on the queen side this is the game hammer kulov against guerrero spain 2008
so for example if black plays e6 here i think a good way to follow up would be to get this
knight around not to d2 that's not the destination right this is a frankfurt airport move where is
the knight going it's going to f3 to support its brother and potentially also jump into e5
white could also contribute to the pressure with b4 so definitely a very practical line there
and if black plays knight bd7 which i think is more popular then they give the rare moves queen
b3 again defending the pawn and this is easy to remember because you play queen b3 against both
bishop d7 and knight d7 if black plays knight to b6 then we deliver the check now with a bishop
bishop d7 and c4 black plays e6 but now e6 no longer comes with the same effect because after
de black has to recapture with the pawn and that is incredibly awkward if black has to recapture
with a pawn then there's no more compensation bishop d6 this is some game that they're giving
brunovich janzel 2018 so pretty recent game takes takes queen e3 queen e7 d3
e3 castles queen e2 and they give plus minus yeah black is virtually no compensation because he
himself has a backward pawn on e6 finally if black plays move 5g6 trying to just fianchetto then we
develop our pieces modestly with bishop e2 avoid bishop c4 because that walks right into knight b6
castles castles if knight b6 again it's time for c4 and if b6 then d3 bishop b7 again we play c4
and again if black plays e6 then he has to recapture with the pawn and here they claim
after knight g4 black's pieces are very active and white's defense is not easy at all um oh
um oh so i apologize this line apparently equalizes for black so their improvement
on move 9 is the immediate c4 white should not lose a tempo for the move d3 but try instead to
advance d4 at once bishop b7 knight c3 e6 trade oh and rather than playing d3 you open up the
center immediately with d4 and here they claim that white is a slight advantage takes takes knight
c5 queen d1 everything is nicely defended knight fe4 bishop e3 trade and they claim a slight
advantage for white white is up a pawn and the central piece mass is very very compact here
so definitely something that i would investigate further but for all intents and purposes this is
absolutely a line that you could play and expect to get an advantage in so rather than our move
which was bishop b5 check similar idea but you do it with the queen queen a4 check and uh against
both responses the queen moves back to b3 if bishop d7 queen b3 attacks the pawn i think bishop
d7 is just a bad move and here you defend the pawn but at some point you take the plunge and
you open up the center getting a better end game and if black plays knight bd7 then you still play
queen b3 and here you do try to keep your extra pawn if knight b6 then you throw in this other
check and then follow up with c4 in order so that after e6 de black cannot recapture with the bishop
all right i think and g6 might be black's best move but not a lot of people are going to know
this and now you develop develop and then at some point you protect the pawn with c4
with c4 in order also to get the c3 square for the knight and then you try to go d4 in one fell swoop
so hopefully that was relatively clear that this is khalif bond's recommendation against 9f6
and definitely we can continue playing this with black i mean very few people are going to know
this especially know this by heart my bishop b5 check is obviously a totally viable alternative
it might even be what they recommend in the chess of course i don't know i'll check this after the
stream black plays bishop knight bd7 which is correct and now we open up the center with d4
a6 is definitely the only correct move for black so once again if black had played 95 this is hasty
because here white simply emerges up a pawn and after e6 i think we can drive this pawn down to
c6 and make things even worse for black black has to trade and in this position i would not
grab a second pawn because that walks right into bishop b7 with a huge initiative instead
i would just develop my pieces with knight f3 also because this could threaten 95 here definitely
black has insufficient compensation no question about it after a6 we bring our bishop back
black recaptures on d5 and now i like our decision to play c4 and d5 i think this is
extremely testing and i actually think that black's main mistake came here i think g6 as natural as it
is might be a serious inaccuracy after which black is struggling quite a bit to equalize and i don't
think equality is possible after this move instead what should black consider doing immediately this
is actually what happened in my game or in the uh rapid chess championship the one time i played
it yeah black actually should go b5 immediately not e6 this is a terrible structure for black
here white is definitely better but black should go for the benko style idea immediately with b5
and after cb5 black goes knight b6 and the chief difference is that black is able to win back the
pawn on d5 if we compare this to the situation where our opponent played b5 which was here what
is the difference well still black should have played knight b6 still black should have played
knight b6 and here i also think that black is able to win back the pawn so the interesting thing is
that if we follow the course of the game and i did just check this with the engine i mentioned
this during the game but it might have been worth spending a tempo maybe after knight c3 to play the
move a4 and prevent black from playing b5 i really think this was worth a tempo somehow i forgot that
knight b6 wins back the pawn but the most clinical continuation for black is to not procrastinate and
immediately play b5 and knight b6 and if white plays b takes a6 i think the simplest is just
to recapture the pawn because this pawn is not going anywhere and after the trade black is going
to win back the pawn on d5 and i think black is very close to equalizing here the engine gives
the move queen e2 hitting the rook and if the rook moves away then there's a very nasty check on b5
so black has to be very careful here and apparently the move for black is c4 intercepting the queen
knight c3 knight f takes d5 trade on d5 knight f3 now both sides develop e6 castles bishop e7
and this position is approximately equal white has a nice past pawn but black has very active
pieces the engine gives zeros so this is indeed the equalizing line but it's hard i mean you got
us you got to know to play b5 and you got to know to play knight b6 so it takes quite a few
accurate moves to equalize here so definitely you could repeat this in one of your games and you can
expect to get a good position okay so in the game our opponent decided to first develop the king
side which i think is fine once again perhaps a4 was a little bit more precise from our perspective
to prevent b5 because after b5 c takes b5 definitely a takes b5 is a very serious mistake
it's an automatic move right it's very natural to recapture but that allows our bishop to jump
into a very active square and now black is too late to go knight b6 because here we have bishop
c6 protecting the pawn this is the chief difference if black plays knight b6 immediately then we're
unable to defend this pawn with our bishop and again if we play ba then black can either take
on a6 or in this case i think black can take on d5 first and white could end up being worse
in a position like this because black's pieces are much more active this is like a dream benko
setup engine gives queen c2 and black just recaptures and in this position apparently
white is worse just because look at the activity that black has reached i mean white can barely
move a muscle the bishop is tied down to the pawn the other pawn is hanging the rook's coming in
this is what you're trying to avoid on the white side of a benko structure even though you are
technically up a pawn so knight b6 did equalize here apparently white should play bishop to e3
counterattacking the c5 pawn and now you get some sort of mass liquidation takes takes takes takes
takes and if you play rook b1 then black simply drops the bishop back with some sort of equal
position bishop c4 is the engine move counterattacking the knight yeah things get very
complicated here but black is not worse black is not worse so the key for our opponent would have
been to go knight b6 immediately that just shows you the level of subtlety that accompanies lines
at this level so but hopefully everybody understood the logic okay so our opponent decided to take on
b5 first and that is what gave us the big advantage bishop b7 now i decided on the move bishop b3 and
perhaps my other candidate move would have been a little bit more to the point which was bishop f4
with the idea of meeting knight b6 with d6 this also now that i look at this after the game this
seems very very appealing to white and i think white is clearly better here as well obviously
if black takes then we take back with the bishop and at the end the rook on f8 is going to be
it is going to be trapped this is not acceptable so i think bishop f4 is is is perhaps even more
precise but bishop b3 looks pretty good as well okay knight b6 made sense just to reiterate why
bishop c6 is a bad move here black can play queen b6 as i pointed out during the game the last thing
that we want is to help black's queen get to this ideal square and ultimately we probably will end
up losing the d5 pawn here so don't be hasty develop your pieces bishop b3 and knight b6 this
really transitions the game from i think the positional phase to the tactical phase bishop
takes c5 we take the second pawn black picks up d5 we trade and we play bishop d4 and in retrospect
i do think that e5 is probably a mistake it's an incredibly creative move and kudos to our opponent
for finding it but probably white's advantage could have been minimized if black had played
knight f4 which is what i think black should have done now my plan here was to trade on g7
and actually to avoid taking on d8 right because if you take on d8 here black gets the rook to an
open file black even has the possibility of trading on f3 and infiltrating the second rank
so i think keeping the tension here with a move like a4 would give white a big advantage this is
what i would have done a move like a4 and i think white is clearly better but the game continues
black is quite active but i know that this is pretty technical so let's really get to the fun
part of the game let's discuss the position after queen g5 so takes takes takes and first and
foremost the move queen g5 had to be examined bishop c6 is a critical resource i think without
this resource black's initiative would have been successful maybe we also have knight f3 but bishop
c6 is definitely the best move i just checked with the engine it wins the game black black's
initiative evaporates again queen e5 bishop b7 we can also trade the bishop for the knight
and in the event of the trade black has no more attack knight f4 simply queen f3 that's it there's
no way to even create a threat against white's king if black plays rook ae8 the engine actually
says you can start pushing there is no attack to speak of 92 check is just one check it doesn't
do anything you cannot dislodge the queen from f3 a rookie three would be awesome but there's a pawn
on f2 that's protecting that square so just because it's the middle game and this is another
common misconception doesn't mean that past pawns can't be promoted with the queens on the board
they absolutely can be right so the plan here for white is a4 b4 or just push the a pawn all the way
down a7 because that's a protected square so in any case queen f6 is a lovely idea by our opponent
inducing 97 and now bringing the queen to g5 and here it was crucial for us to find queen f3
so once again why not knight takes f8 apart from 93 even more decisive is knight f4 this is
literally checkmate in three moves because g2 is under fire and white has no way to defend it
and if g3 the knight h3 is made white has to stave it off by playing bishop c6 and then queen f3
that tells you all you need to know so queen f3 is i think a very instructive move and
as i mentioned during the game the way you find these types of moves is you realize that a pin
or an x-ray is a two-way street particularly if the piece that's quote-unquote giving the x-ray
the piece of lower value is also undefended the queen can be just as much of an aggressor as the
bishop can and it's important that black can't bring the rook to b8 that square is protected
by the knight so the bishop will remain undefended on the next move so black plays rook fc8 which i
think is is virtually forced and harold lloyd asks can you analyze rook fd1 instead of a4 so i
i'm proud of a4 i think this is a very calm move which just improves the position because black is
no threat harold suggested rook f to d1 which i also really like i actually think this is a great
move and black has a hard time stopping this brilliant threat of the double capture on d5
even if black plays rook c2 you can still take on d5 i think bishop d5 queen d5 queen d5 knight f6
and then the resulting end game white should definitely be winning here especially because
black is unable i think to win the a2 pawn otherwise that should be a draw
if rook a4 who can tell me how white keeps everything alive what is and i just checked
at the engine this is a very important resource for white otherwise the a2 pawn is lost don't
go bishop b3 and blunder to rook takes b3 so that's what it's not 93 only move we're treating
only move we're treating knight moves knight defends the bishop bishop defends the pawn
and the knight is on a defended square also don't go rook c1 because of the back rank trick with
rook takes c4 so your move harold would be fantastic as well rook fd1 i was like irrationally
worried about black bringing the king up to g7 and i was also reticent about going for this position
because i thought maybe i'm miscalculating something maybe there's some back rank check
i wasn't totally sure and i thought that a4 was a safer option in time pressure because this
basically guarantees that everything is protected and you know moves like a4 are hard to find
especially when there's a lot going on there's a lot of traffic in the position finding a quiet
move that improves your position is hard from a psychological standpoint as well because you feel
like you need to do something the way that you find these types of moves is that you first and
foremost need to figure out whether there is an actual threat right that's the first thing i asked
myself does black have a threat the answer is no because there's no discovery we take the bishop
in all of the cases notice that if black plays 93 we don't take the knight we still take the bishop
and here we can we can take on f1 but even better is to take the rook on f8 so there is literally
nothing that black can do to us i wanted to play knight b6 this is a really creative idea but it
fails because after knight b6 queen b7 guess what the bishop on b5 is hanging that's actually
how i found the move a4 and i thought wait a second if we play a4 to support the bishop not
only does that you know relieve our burden on the queen side it makes this knight b6 idea possible
against a lot of options like if black makes a random move knight b6 is an excellent move
because it forks the rooks and it forces black to give up his only active piece and here white
is simply winning so that was part of the reason that i played a4 big part of the reason and of
course the fact that it pushes the pass pawn which is good in and of itself hopefully the reasoning
makes sense i had other candidate moves here i was seriously contemplating as you guys know rook fe1
And the reason I rejected it is because of Rook c2 and at this point black has some crazy tactical ideas
Here I got scared because at first I thought we could still play Knight b6
but no takes and again the bishop hangs that's not still not possible and
If you play a move like a4 black can already make a draw or come very close to making a draw who can spot
The tactic that black now has which becomes a lot stronger with the rook now sitting on c2
What can black now do that previously led nowhere?
Very nice dark tiger got it Knight f4 is correct
Now what's the chief difference the difference is that here white no longer has the move King f1 because rook takes f2 is checkmate
Compare that to this position here King f1 is not only
Winning but it's the only move and f2 is protected but with the rook on c2
King f1 is not possible black white has to be King h1 and black is able to repeat moves and it's a miracle that black
Isn't mating white. This is a drop and
This is the concept that just because an idea doesn't work in one position
Doesn't mean that it doesn't work in another you have to constantly
Update your perception of the board any any time any piece moves to a more active square
You need to reassess and reevaluate a lot of the key tactical ideas
Which you know are you know need to be carefully calculated night f4 is an obvious move
So you have to keep considering it because things might have changed imperceptibly with the rook
let's say coming to c2 and again, I definitely have some examples of this type of
Thinking leading to a blunder not thinking in this way
But I'd have to think about it and I think we've done enough
so every move, yeah, you have to update the board state, but you can only do it so much, especially in a blitz game, right, you can't spend five minutes reassessing and recalculating
but it's a lot easier at times to do that than it seems here
It's quite easy because you know exactly what the rook is doing
And if you pay attention to the right factors, you'll understand that night f4 a much more powerful threat this time
Once we finish the game, I'll see if I can come up with some examples
Okay, so a4 was played our opponent plays rook c2 and now I went for the practical option of Queen g3
Now turning on the engine yields some crazy stuff. According to the engine
We should have stuck with the rook a d1 idea and after rook takes b2
You guys know the drill rook takes d5 is the simplest and you don't even need Queen takes d5
You can actually just deliver the check immediately and the Queen's on the board favor white because blacks King is in huge trouble. So
Rook a d1 for some reason did not occur to me because I was very worried about Knight f4. Oh
but of course now
Now the King can go to h1 and after Knight takes f2 you can take it
And that is why you bring put the a rook on d1 and not the f rook, right?
That's the difference here Knight f4 makes a draw
This is like what it comes down to when you got these tactical games these small subtle differences
But all of it can be understood right? It's it's logical. It's just hard to see during the game
But also intuitively I would play rook a d1
Because I wouldn't move pieces away from the king with all of black's pieces trained at the king
and after rook a d1 if black plays King g7 our old friend makes an appearance Knight b6 again and
And again, the genius of the way for now shines through because we never have to worry about the hanging Bishop
This is why undefended pieces are so fricking
you know potentially fatal and
What and conversely why keeping your pieces defended by pawns often allows you to benefit in these tactical sequences?
so
We played Queen g3. I think our opponent had to trade
I don't think there was an alternative and what I overlooked is of course that after Bishop c8 Bishop c6
I overlooked the move rook a5. Otherwise black loses at least in exchange
Here black counterattacks the knight and if the knight drops back then the rook defends the other knight
So it's important that black has this move because there's no alternative
The bishop is trapped and if black had played rook a7
Then we take the bishop and fork the rook in the night with Bishop c6 this I saw
this I saw great job by our opponent spotting the tactical detail and now I
Think I did something that I'm pretty proud of because we had only a minute 30
I think a lot of players in general when you're banking on something
You've calculated a sequence and then suddenly you realize that you had overlooked something, right?
It's very important not to just sort of stubbornly play the move
Anyway, I think a lot of players you might relate to this
I've done this before where you almost don't want to believe that the move doesn't work
And so you dig yourself into the hole because you're too lazy to look for other options
But it's important to admit to yourself as quickly as possible. Yes. I overlooked this move
Yes
This actually makes things worse for white because if the knight has to drop back then blacks rooks now get active and whites advantage
virtually evaporates
So you have to double back put a stop to it and and say okay, I'm not playing Bishop c6
How can I improve my position and once you phrase it like that?
I think it's obvious that the rook from f1 needs to get into the game rook fc1 is a very natural move rook fd1
I think would have also been a very good move. I was worried about Knight c3
But apparently this position is good for white
I just checked the engine and the pin against the bishop is very strong, but this is kind of hard to evaluate
And I thought rook fc1 is a harder move to face practically because it restricts the knight it defends the c3 square
And black could have maintained drawing chances here with the move knight b4
The engine gives about plus two. It's still definitely a winning endgame
We would have traded the other rook and I don't think this is defensible from a human standpoint
Also because the knight has to go back to a6
Now, of course, there is bishop c6 and knight b3 very similar to what we did in the game
Our opponent hastened his defeat with bishop f5 now again
Just because the move doesn't work in one position doesn't mean you have to stop checking it
That's why we played rook fc1 to protect the knight taking the sting out of rook a5
And luckily we have this move knight b7 dislodging the rook from d8
dislodging the rook from d8
okay, and that ends the game because
Okay, the best that black could do is to give up the exchange
But without the a pawn there would be technique required with the a pawn. This is
Elementary win elementary win. Okay, so I wish I had some ready-made examples of
Some of the the principles that we outlined but still we've done a lot of analysis in this game
So I think that will be sufficient any questions
Because there there's a lot a lot that we talked about. We covered the theory which was queen a4 check
we
examined
Sort of typical benko like ideas the black has to carry out and then we covered the theory
The black has to carry out in order to equalize just for the sake of completeness the benko gambit
Which I should have showed earlier is d4 net of 64 c5. This is the entry point to the benoni e6 is the modern benoni
Where black fianchetto is the bishop the benko is b5 also called the volga gambit in russia
b5
So you sacrifice the pawn and then typically you play the move a6 and here you can see the similarity in the structure
in the sense that black has the open a and b files that he will try to use to put pressure on white's queen side
and usually
The dark squared bishop is fianchettoed here
and that's
About it white does not have to play ba by the way
In the benko white often sacks the pawn back with a move like b6 to keep the queen side closed
So the benko is uh an incredibly complex opening in its own, right?
But black had to demonstrate those ideas in order to equalize asap. So our opponent didn't play b5
We could have prevented it with a4 on several different occasions
And here the big mistake was to play the automatic move which helps our bishop get active
Knight b6 seems to equalize for black then later
Um fast forwarding to the next important moment. We kind of initiate a series of trades
So kind of knowing what you want to accomplish is important and not buying your opponent's bluff, right?
Bishop e5 queen g5 looks very scary, but you calculate one move further and then you find bishop c6
And once again here as well, it seems like the move knight d7 fails
But you don't have to assume that knight takes f8 is forced
You have to look for other moves queen f3 comes to the rescue and the rest was pretty smooth
We're getting some questions about a couple different opening lines. Remember
That there will be dedicated youtube videos on all of the allopen lines
Okay, so that's separate from the speedrun
I will cover the theory in a series of videos including the move e5 which we have not faced
But is a recommendation of some youtubers
Definitely need to know how to respond white can get an advantage here
So it's it's not the end of the world, but uh, you can wait for those and hopefully we'll face
More theoretically testing all up in lines during the speedrun
And have a great start to your week and everybody. Thanks for hanging out